(musiikkia)
Olen Haikutortan tyttö ja haluan tietää, että tuota paljonko Suomella on piljaa varastossa, jos sattuu useassa sotatilanne ja huonoa aikaa ettei saa.
Siitä, että sellaisia peltoja, mitkä vaan niitetään hukkaa eikä korjata satoa, niin sellaisille pelloille ei pitäisi maksaa tukea. Tai sitten jos ei nyt tänä kesän kerki kylväämään niitä kevätviljalle, niin ne on kylvettävä sit syysviljalle. Tai muuten ei tuki ja tipu. Tää on ihan päärin, että maksetaan tukea sellasta tyhjästä työstä.
Eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tällä kertaa kuulemme kritiikkiä Mäntyniemen peruskorjauksesta, ajatuksia lentävästä autosta ja kaivataanpa myös hanurimusiikkia Lappeen rantaan.
Ohjelman osat on tässä jaksossa asettanut paikoilleen Koiviston Lauri. Yksi soittaja ehdottaa eduskuntatalolle uutta nimeä. Toinen kansalainen haluaisi nostaa pullojen panttimaksua ja ihmetelläänpä myös missä ovat hirvilven hirvet. Nyt on aika palata vielä Vapun tunnelmiin.
Se oli sovittu mitkä on panerollit. Saa olla mukana ja kaikki tarkastetaan etukäteen ja pukeutuminen. Me olimme rauhanomaiset marssimaiset ja sitten sinne rikotaan määräyksiä. Tullaan sivusta ja ämnesti oikea anarkistit hyökkäävassarit sinne. Alkaa natsit vittuun panerollia pitämään eli se oli lainvastainen. Häirittiin yleistä rauhallista vappumarssia ja me olemme sopimusyhteiskunta niin kuin presidenttissä.
Me olemme rauhaan rakastavia. Me ketkä marssimme siellä järjestäytyneesti ja meillä on perhe. Me olemme naamion takana koska minulla ainakin on yli kahdesataa tuhannen euron tämmöinen ongelma tullut kun nämä asemistolaiset ovat hajottaneet Meikomanin omaisuutta ynnä muuta. Haluamme olla anonneleja mutta haluamme olla vapaassa Suomessa määräysten mukaan toimia. Eli tämmöinen anarkistinen ja uhrjutuninen mitä tuolta puhutaan.
Eli vasemmistosta päin tulee nyt pois semmoinen että katsotaan että antaa meidän jää rauhassa olla niin me olemme jää rauhassa. Me emme tunkeudu teillä tiloilla. Ei muuta. Ei.
No heitä hei. Ex pääministeri Antti Rinne lupasi aikoinaan eläkeläisille Vakku Satas eipä ole tilinen. Ei. Siinä oli puhetta aiemmasta pääministeristä. Niinpä nyt onkin paikallaan puhua tasavallan.
Presidentin virka asunnosta Hei Kansanradio. Nyt valmistuu tälle Tupiliokeen kunnollinen Mäntynienen kämppä eikä maksa kuin viiskytviis miljoonaa. Ehkä ehkä enemmänkin alkaa olla valmis. Kyllä tä löytyy Suomesta rahaa. Herra Juhkeli sentä ei olla köyhiä eikä kipeitä mutta kuristetaan. Kaikkia muita kurjia kuristetaan. Kyllä se ressa olisi asunut siinä vanhassakin että kyllä tä on ihan ihmeellistä. Sitten kuristetaan ihan kaikki.
ja vanhuksia ja kaikkia töyhiä ja työttömia ja surkeita muita, että ei millään ole enää mitään rajaa.
Ei se nyt varmaan olisi vaatinut siihen mitään peruskorjausta, että eiköhän se olisi kelvannut sellaisenaankin. Siis aivan karmeeta, kun kattelee minkälainen lukaali pitää olla. Ihmettelee vaan tommoistakin tuhlaamista.
Ohjelman remonttiakin, että kyllä sillä 55 miljoonalla olisi ollut käyttöä vanhustenhoitoa ja monta parannusta olisi saatu ja maksettua niitä velkoja. Tämä vaan lentelee maasta toiseen ja veronmaksajien rahaa palaa. Semmonen presidentti meillä. Just just. Ja etsille. Nani, hyvää kesäjatkua kaikille, hei.
Ennen niitä puheluita vielä Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella lähetetty viesti vallan toisesta aiheesta. Siinä lukee näin:
Tällä tavoin luki viestissä, jonka Maria Liisa oli lähettänyt Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Ja ne vaatii vähän niin kuin myös lainsäädännön uudistusta, mutta tällä näen, että kännissä ajoa saa nyt niin satsattaa euroa niin kuin ota sakkoja. Nostettaa se kahdeksasadasta niin viiteensataa kerralla.
Eli kunnon sakko.
Kunnon sakko ja sitten tällainen kaverikyydikunahan näitähän ei saa kaveria olla kyydin niin samanlainen niin laittaa niin viissattaa euroa per kaveri ja alkaa niin kuin kiinnostamaan tää lainsäädäntöä.
Valtio kasjan kannalta hyvä sitten.
Joo, että aina kun on ylimääräinen niin jokainen maksaa viissattaa. Sitten on tämmönen edotus, että Englannissa on tällainen takavarikoinnin, niin otetaan tää takavarikoinnin käyty.
Eli mitä takavarikoidaan?
Sähköpotkulauta. Sitä tulee niin kuin rotiajien järjestössä tähän niin kuin käyttöön ja alkaa tuntua. No on sitten omaa tai vuokralautaa niin sille on mitään merkitystä.
Ehdotuksesi on, että kunnon sakot jos ajaa Humalassa tai sitten yli yksi siinä kyydissä ja sitten takavarikoidaan lauta.
Joo ja sitten semmoiseen niin kuin säilytykseen. Kiitoksia paljon näistä ehdotuksista ja oikein hyvää sunnuntajatkoa. Ja kypärä pakko käyttöön ei muuta niin. No niin, no hei.
Kiina on kehittänyt sen lentävän auton. Siitä on mun yks ystävättäreni kyllä puhunut jo kolmekymmentä vuotta sitten ja hänelle nauremma kaikki niin heleästi, mutta Kiina on sen kehittänyt.
Ja Länsi Suomessa, jolloin pitkät työmatkat, ne sai semmoisella pienellä rahalla tämmöisen lentävän auton. Ei se huonompi ajatus ole, kun meillä on niin iso tämä ja pitkä ja leveä tämä. Ei niin leveä, mutta pitkä on maa niin että voisi oikeasti ajatella näitä kauppoja niin kuin eikä vaan tämmöstä pientä piperrystä. Ja sitten ei tarvitse. Lentävä auto semmoisen. Nehän on kaksi ihmistä mahtuu kun työmatkoja taattelee vaikka. Ja sitten tietysti voisi näitä tämmöisiä autoja kehitellä sinne kuorta.
Länsi Suomien vetämiseen tai itse asiassa junia enemmänkin, mutta kuitenkin jotka osaisivat toimia ihan itekseenkin ettei siellä tarvitsisi sen ukon istua. Akan istua siellä tunti tolokulaan perään ja kulettaa sitä isoa kuormaa sinne tänne tuonne. Eli jotain niille maantielläkin pitäisi olla ja radoillakin kulkea, mutta se ihmisten pääsy sieltä. Kyllähän mummotkin voisi lähteä sieltä kyliltä lentämään sinne terveyskeskukseen, koska sinnehän on saavutettu.
Satakilomaisia ja synnyttämää voisi mennä, kun nehän on semmoisia että ne synnyttää joskus. Jos synnyttävät, että se olisi semmoinen hyödynnettävä asia ihmisen kannalta. Se semmoinen lentävä auto. Kiitoksia paljon tästä ehdotuksesta ja jäädään seuraamaan että koska päästään lentämään autolla. Tehkään ehdotus. Okei, no niin selvä. Jo okei. Siinä mainittiin Kiina. Aivan pian korviimme marssi kahta muuta valtiota koskevat puheenvuoroja.
Niitä edeltää sähköposti, jossa palataan viime jaksojen aiheisiin. Viestissä lukee näin: Herralle, jonka mielestä ikeihmiset eivät saisi äänestää, meni väärin päin. Yli kuusikymmentävuotiaat ei saisi olla missään muodossa ehdolla missään vaaleissa, ovat sen verran tapoinsa juurtuneita etteivät näe metsää puilta. Ja Espoolaiselle, joka valitteli suomen kielen murteista. Suomen kieli on eri murteista.
Murteita, niitä siinä itsekin väänsit, joten Suomen kielen monimuotoisuus kunniaan eikä Englannin kielen käännösmongerruksia. Näin lukee sähköpostissa, jonka on lähettänyt esimerkki Maaseutu ja murteet kunniaan. Kansarion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.atyle.fi.
Trumpin rääkymisistä, uhkailuistahan on ihan humpuukia ja ei niitä kaikkia tarvitsa aina huudella.
Ja kun huudellaan ja puhutaan varsinkin radio uutisissa, sieltä on ottuu tosi tärkeitä asioita, erittäin tärkeitä.
Trump uhkaa Natosta eroamisella. Sitä kyllä Yle toimittajat huutavat, mutta eivät sano sitä tärkeää asiaa. Trump ei voi tehdä niin.
Siihen tarvitaan kongressin enemmistöpäätös ja se ei tule ikimaailmassa menemään läpi, joten ei tehdä tarpeettomia uhkakuvia, ei luoda tarpeettomia uhkakuvia.
Toki Trumpihan on täysin sekopää ja sillä on liikaa valtaa, aivan liikaa valtaa. Mutta muistetaan aina kertoa suomalaisille kuitenkin, että ei Trumpi kaikkea voi tehdä Yhdysvalloissa.
Esimerkiksi hän ei voi määrätä Natosta eroamista eikä myöskään muiden maiden erottamista. Esimerkiksi Espanjan ultafaktoilla ei mennä Trumpin jokaiseen mielipuolisuuteen mukaan. Kiitos, hei!
Seuraavaksi on luvassa kotimaan politiikkaan liittyviä kysymyksiä ja ehdotuksia.
No JKH Tampereelta. Minulla olisi kyllä taas sulle hyvä tämmönen semmoinen hyvä huumoripohjainen ehdotus. No niin, mieleeni kuuntelen. Hei katos kun tää eduskuntatalohan on eduskuntatalo nimeltään, mutta mä ehdottaisin tälläinen huumoripohjalta tehdä siitä höylännollatalo nimeksi. No mistäs tällainen idea? No sen takia kuuluu siellä sehdään aika höylännoja päätöksiä ja.
Ääriä päätöksiä näin poispäin. Onko joku tietty päätös nyt viime aikoina joka ajaa nyt mieleen vai onko teillä? No siellä on vaikka kuinka monta nää hallituksen päätökset niin kyllä niin. Ja sitä YDP mitä minä kannatan, niin sanon suoraan ne ei tee mitään ehdotuksia vaikka ne koko ajan ylittää hallituksen ehdotuksia. Humota tätä takia sitten itsekin tehdään niin sen takia mä haluaisin että sillä olisi hyvä nimi, tämmönen huumoripohjainen nimi niin jos tää eduskuntatalous tehdet tässä niin.
Hylmölätalo. Hylmölätalo. No niin kiitoksia paljon tästä ehdotuksesta ja oikein hyvää sunnutatkoa sinne Tampereelle. Kuin myös sinulle ja nythän on äitien päivä niin vietetään sitäkin samalla vaikka mun vanhemmat on jo kyllä haudassa mutta siitä huolimatta. Näin tehdään kiitoksia paljon. Kiitos kiitos sinulle moro moro. Tiedusteleva kansalainen tässä päivään. Minä haluaisin tietää semmoise asia että paljako se tämä nykyhallitus.
On ottanut uutta velkaa tälle Suomenmaalle. Oiskohan sitä kenellään tietoa? Onko minuksella vai onko plussalla? Heippa.
Rikollisia kun ovat vastustaa tätä maamioihin pois jälttämistä niin se on minusta ihmet että tämmöisissä asioissa ei ole yksimielisyyttä tuntutta. Roikalleita rikolliset on kasvatunut sinne Artkadionmäelle. Tätä meiltä mennään lepparalla.
Täytelijää puhutaan. Hei. Tänään tervelemme. Tuossa oli Voitankansa puhetta niin meillä on kuusi puoluetta joten ei tarvitsisi. Ihan täällä tarvitsisiko kokoomuksia Venari ja ruotsalaiset. Niin kuusi puoluetta niin niihin menee kauhjasti raakaan kun niitä työtettäjiä ja isot herrat on siellä niin sietähän vastaa supistaa kyllä. Mutta onhan se kyllä semmoinen homma että.
Ei korppi korppin silmää nuki kyllä ettei ei. Joo tämähän on silmä ilma ja ei muuta kuin hyvää jaskua.
Höpöhallituksesta. Oikein höpö ja se ei ole onnistunut missään mittään.
Kulut ovat liian isot ja hoitotyöhön jää liian vähän rahaa. SDP-vasemmisto ja vihreät taas laittavat maahanmuuttajien asiat tärkeimmiksi.
Tuota yks huolestunut tässä ihmettelee tätään nykymaailman meno. Miten noista vanhuksista on kirjoitettu useassa lehdessä? Kuinka huonosti heitä kohdellaan? Minä en ymmärrä miksi tämä maailma on mennyt tällaiseksi. Minun mummoni asui aikoinaan toisen minun vanhempien kotona hänen toisen lapsensa perheessä. Elikkä minun.
Aitini veli hoiti minun mummoni. Hän sai asua rauhallisessa perheessä ja näin oli ennen. Miksi tämä maailma on mennyt tällaiseksi? Tämä on aivan kamalaa luettavaa ja tätä pääsee lapsekin lukemaan tuolta internetistä. Ei oikein hyvältä kyllä näytä, mutta ei kai tässä auta kuukausinta. Kahvi tulelee ja kohti uusia seikkailuja.
Maria Mori ja Mori ja kuulin äsken oikein mahtavan esityksen. Mumeli jostain pohjoisesta esitti, että tämmöinen työterveyshuolto pitäisi niin sanotusti lakkauttaa ja pistää ne lääkärit johonkin muualle ihan samalla tavalla jonon kuin tavalliset kansalaiset. Ja aikaisemmin siinä ajateltiin varmaan, että työntekijän pitää päästä mahdollisimman nopeasti takaisin töihin, mutta kun eduskunnassakin esimerkiksi.
Joku terveysministeri sanoo, että ei se terveyskeskus maksu kovin montaa kertaa ihmiselle tule. Kyllähän se tulee ja työterveyshuoltohan senhän maksaa työnantaja ja osittain tietysti työntekijäkin. Eipä jos siellä päivän pari joku odottaa jossain sairaana, niin huihai ei muuta kuin tavallisten ihmisten jononia. Eli siis ehdotuksesi on, että työterveyshoito pitäisi lopettaa? Juu, juu kyllä ja siirtää kaikki tähän perusteella.
Eli terveyskeskuksen jonot pitenevät sitten siinä? Ei kun ne lyhenevät kun lääkärit jotka ovat nyt osa aikaisesti hoitaa oman vastaanottonsa ohella tätä työterveyshuoltoa, niin ne menisivät sitten terveyskeskukseen hoitamaan lääkäritä. Ja te luulet että näin tapahtui sitten? Juu totta kai tapahtuu. Katsos siellä on rahaa taustalla. Sitten kun raha loppuu, niin sitten pitää keksiä jostain muualta sitä tuloa. Selvä. Jos ei enää tule työterveyshuollosta, niin sitten se tulee työterveyshuoltoon.
- Tulkaa sieltä jostain muualta. - Kiitoksia paljon tästä kanalatusta. - Hyvä, kiitoksia. Hyvää päivänjattua. - Hei, hei. Siitä samaa. Hei.
(Telefon täällä antaa virus. Tulen pian käymään teillään. Heippa.) - Heippa. Kiitoksia soitosta. - Tässä on sitten tältä Pohjanmaalta kaikille Suomen päättäjille, kuntapäättäjille semmoisia terveisiä, että ottaisivat huomioon, että ei aina kaikilta pieniltä köyiltä -
paikkakunnilta viedä sairaaloita ja sairaanhoitaja pois ja sairaaloita lopeteta. Pitäisi tehdä niin, että sieltä tihjästä paikasta, missä on liikaa ihmisiä, niin sieltä tuotaisiin sairaita sinne pienempään paikkakuntaan, että sielläkin saisi pysyä saira. Eikö olisikin asiaa, että ei aina pienempiä hävitetä, kun otettaisiin sieltä isommilta lainaksi sinne pienempään paikkakuntaan niitä hoidettavia, ettei tarvitsisi sitten hävittää sairaala.
Näin on, eikö vaan? Heippa! Heippa sinnekin! Jatkammekin sote-teemoilla tähän väliin kerron, että seuraavaksi kuullaan WhatsAppilla lähetetty viesti. Sen saateviestissä lukee, että:
Viisi, viisi, yksi, viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä.
Terveisit vaan täältä Laesta Kansanradioon. Vähän valitusta siitä hammaslääkäristä.
Silloin kun tehdään potilaalle viisana hampaan poisto nukutuksessa ilman puudutusta, niin musta se on väärin, että ne hinnat on niin hirveän kalliita, mutta se on erittäin väärin.
Se ei ole yhtään kivaa. Minun mielestä hinnat pitäisi laskea tai laittaa vaikka alhaisemmaksi.
Onko nyt tilanne se, että sinulla ei ole ollut varaa viisina hampaan poistoon nukutuksessa?
Ei ole nyt ollut, koska kun me käytimme silloin siellä, niin sitten ne sanoivat sieltä, että ne ovat tosi kalliita. Se viisina hampaa poisto poistamatta taisi jäädä, niin tarvetus olisi mennä sinne.
Minä en ymmärrä, että jos sinne menee sinne missä se lääkäri suositteli, niin musta se on ihan outo. Siis musta se on väärin, että siellä ne hinnat ovat tosi korkeat.
Hinnat alas ja hoito ylös välittävästi. Täältä hyvinvointiyhteiskunnasta Porvoon seudulta tervehdys tuli juuri tuolta terveysasemalta. Arvauskeskuksessa kansanomaisesti tunnetumpi paikka, niin ihmettelen sitä kävin. Olin kahden eri lääkärin vastaanotolla siellä, niin miksi minulla ei ole oikeus saada tulkkia suomen- tai ruotsinkielisenä paikalla, kun nämä maahanmuuttajat saavat tulkita.
Minulla ei veronmaksajana ole oikeutta saada tulkkia, että minulla lääkärillä löytyisi yhteisymmärrys ja yhteinen kieli. Kiitos, hei.
Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Viisi kilometriä tunnissa maksimissaan siinä. Toinen mikä siihen, että laitetaan Tarina-raitto viiden metrin välein koko sillan matkalta, että muista sen sellaisen, että liikunta saa. Tässä on helppo ja halpa ratkaisu. Viikonmerkki ja sitten Montun kohtaan vedetään siihen koko puolentoista kilometriä matkaa Tarina-raitto. Ei.
Mutta sitten mä en tiedä mistä semmoinen sanonta tuleekten. Nyt otti ohraleipä eli nyt otti ohraleipä. Kaljaa tarvitaan ohraa. Kiitos.
Olisi piisasta nostaa pankin hinta vaikka euroon taikka vitosen, niin ei heitä tässä. Kiitos. No vii, taas soittaa Lapinukko Kansanradio. Minä kävin tuolla kirjastossako. Siinä on vähän muutoksia tehty ja sieltä meinasin muutaman paperin virkapaperin kirjoittaa, niin siinä oli nuoria naisia, niin kukaan ei halunnut neuvoa.
Sitä uutta koneettakos ei oli erilainen kuin ennen. Meidän verorahoilla ostetaan paskakoneja joita ei kukkaan osaa käyttää. Hyvin ylipiasti sanon vaan tyvän ettei he saa auttaa asiakkaita. Minä etten ole mitään varten te täällä olette neljä tonttia kuukausipalakalla toljuttomassa. Ei auttanut, ei. Mutta se on juuri tämä kun ne luulee että he saa koko maailmaa jos me vanhukset kuulemme pois huomenna. Minä täytän kohta kahdeksankymmentä ja minä kyllä varmaan olen satakaksikymmentä.
Tavoite on aivan pirruttani. Kyllä on maailman mennä mallit. On tuossa vanhan kirjaston aikana ennen kuin oli muuttanut siinä sitä järjestelmää niin siellä sentään oli kaks laista jotka neuvoivat sen tietokunnan. Eihän me kahdeksankymmentä sen edes saa näitä chattipattipattipattipottipottikättkottikottia ja käyttää. Kyllä pitää sanoa että on tämä hurjaa hommaa. Minä lähden tässä kävelyskyvän vielä ulos kun ei mukava ili vaan aurinkovaista.
Sajan linnut laulaa taitaa tulla kesä. Allismäättä täällä Lapinolaista raportoja täällä kun kaiken niköistä rokkijuhlaa järjestetään että eilenkin tuossa vanhansa arvokkaansa nuija miehestä niin kaiken maailman hippejä oli siellä pitkiä katua perässä täällä näin hirveitä möykkää musiikkia ja vieraita ihmisiä niin eivätkö elisenkiläisiä tulleet tänne kylille pillaamaan meidän fiiliksemme. En minä arvosta tällaista että kyllä se perään pitäisi olla oikeita kulttuuria hanuri musiikkia tai humppaa. Muuta ei tarvitse.
Lapinola se ei ole muuta. Lappeenrannan humppa toiveesta siirrymme teeveemaailmaa koskeviin kannanottoihin. Niitä edeltää vielä yksi kirje aivan muusta aiheesta. Siinä lukee seuraavasti kirkossa lauletaan virsiä ja välillä saa kuulla esimerkiksi joidenkin kuorojen laulavan toisentapaisia lauluja. Tähän mennessä en ole kuullut kirkossa yhtään näitä jokapäiväisiä lauluja joissa esiintyy kirosanoja.
Se on hyvä se. Näin luki kirjeessä, jonka oli lähettänyt esimerkki Eras kuuntelija.
Sen ala-arvoiseen puhetyyliin. Ohjelma päällikkö voisi vähän miettiä, mikä olisi vaihtoehto, vaikka kullitus ja sitä, mitä sieltä telkusta ulos tulee. Ei muuta. Heippa.
Se tarvitsee katsoa. Mikähän pakko katsoa? Toimetko itse tällä tavalla? Kyllä toimitka useinkin, jos on hyvä ohjelma mielestäsi. Aika hyvä poliittinen keskustelu. Askudin on aika hyvä. Sitä suosittelette? Joo, katsoin aika usein. Ja nyt on nämä vaalikeskustelu. Keskustelu meni vähän tylsä, kun ei ole väärisempaa kuin enää siellä. Oikeastaan ollaan kyllä kyllä mitä minä sanoin. Kyllä minä sanoin.
Kyllä minä tiedän. Kyllä minä en. En minä. En minä ole tämmöstä sanonut. Semmosta sanonut. Ja vaikka olisinkin sanonut niin toivittain varosti ymmärtänyt sinua väärin.
Että väyristä kaipaa takaisin. No, no joo Paavo oli aito. Ja hän. No aina hän oli oikeassa. Ja jäädään seuraamaan että palaako Paavo vielä poliittiselle kentille. Tuleeko unki ja Paavo ja. Kiitoksia Teemu. Sinne Tuusula ei oikein hyvää sununta jatkaa. Joo joo. Hyvä äitienpäivä kaikille kaikille äideille mitä te kuululla on. Toivottavasti koko Suomea. Aoi.
Riikka Kuopiossa tätä. Hei missä on hirvet hirviliveistä? Äitienpäivä oli ja meni tältä vuodelta, mutta ehdottomasti siitä voi vielä runoilla. Kiitos jo etukäteen kaikille näille runoilijoille. Ennen lyyrisiä teoksia kerron Kansanradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 0 8 0 0 1 5 4 6 4.
Ja puhelu on soittajalle maksuton ja muistuksena että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaaja kolmen tunnin ajan. Äitirukka olit ainoa kaunis kukka. Taivas katsoo minua, mutta minä en unohda sinua. Voi kun tietäis mitä olisin tehnyt toisin auttaisin sinua jos voisin. Sillä kauniit ajatukset.
Ovat kuin sielulle sympatiaa. Näin kohti kesää. Hyvää äitienpäivää kaikille. Toivottaa pikkurilankari. - Tässä Sirpa Tuomala lausui äitienpäivän runo. Milloin se oikein tulee? Se äidin oma päivä, kyselee lapsetuskaskuneena. Elipoisimme kakun jos vain osaisimme, mutta ehkä isä ostaa varmiin kaupasta tai konditoriasta.
Me piirrämme kyllä kortin valmiiksi äidille ja mummille. Äidissä saa loihtia ruokaa varhansa mukaan. Hän yrittää kyllä Efilina yllä säheltää. Kokonaislohen hän uuninlaittaa ja valkoviimiä päälle lorauttaa. Siitä saa kuulemma juhlavamman ja maukaan hän suurella äänellä toitettaa. Sitten juhlekset pilkkuu ja vieraini laittaa. Kohta on mitä laittaa pöytä ja sitten narslissit ulkoaa malja.
Eihän se haittaa jos ei juuri nyt ole ruusia laittaa. Sitten kahvin keittoilla lapset vientävät äitiä hakemaan ja korttia tuomaan. Eikä sitten muuta kuin syömään ja juomaan äitien päivänä. Onnea kaikille!
Ruusun saa heitä muistetaan onnitellaan. Tulee äitejä muistaa muulloinkin joka päivä auttaen kiittäjän. Ajatuksessaan heitä siunaten. Tulee kaikille aika ei äitiä oo. Muistot kauniit kuitenkin tallella sillon ruusuja enää ei tarvita. Ei niitä silloin voi antaa. Onnea Suomen äideille tänä päivänä kaikkien äitien Olavi.
Samoin lopuksi kuljemme äitien päivästä viisutunnelmiin. Ennen viimeisiä puheluita Minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää. Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa Kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
Niin Kansanradio jonka yksi äiti ei taas ohi. Jokainen on viettänyt omalla tavallaan tai jättänyt viettämättä mutta semmoinen tuli vaan mieleen että voisiko tuo mitaleitten jakaminen ja juhlistaminen tällä lailla presidentin taholta loppua koska se jotenkin tuntuu hankalalta siinä mielessä että ikään kuin äidit olisivat eriarvoisia toiset ansaisivat mitalinja ja toiset sitten eivät mitään. Minun mielestä jokainen äiti.
On samanarvoinen ja jokainen sen tekee omalla tavallaan ja se äitiys lähtee sydämestä ja rakkauden tekona oman lastaan kohtaan. Sitä ei voi mitaleilla mitata eikä palkita. Tärkein palkinto on se että säilyälleet lapsien kanssa keskinäinen rakkaus ja kunnioitus. Kiitos tästä äitienpäivästä omalle lapselleni.
Rakkauden hinta. Hei! No Paula terve! Mä otan nyt kantaa tuohon euroviisun kun just kuuntelin Kansanradio nyt alkaa huumaa ole ja kun kuuntelee näitä juttuja niin mehän ollaan jotain voitettu mutta Jumala varjele meitä voiton. Ensi vuonna meille ei sittu enää kuin kuusi kertaa samat uutiset päivässä ja silleen että heippa!
Eli ed.